merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à madame isabelle le callennec ma
question s'adresse à la ministre de la
justice qui a préféré aux questions
d'actualité
la clôture des assises de la protection
de l'enfance à rennes rennes capitale de
la bretagne mais aussi théâtre c'est
d'éviter benne d'un nouveau genre dans
la soirée de mercredi à jeudi une
trentaine de jeunes du quartier de
villejean en grande partie des mineurs
est descendu dans le centre ville pour
régler ses comptes avec une bande rivale
batte de baseball barres de fer et
autres clubs de golf était de la partie
sont clairement mis en cause une
vingtaine de mineurs étrangers isolés ou
prétendus tels jeudi prétendus tels car
il est admis qu'un bon tiers des jeunes
accueillis sur notre territoire se
déclarant mineurs ont en réalité plus de
18 ans
or s'ils sont mineurs ils sont de la
responsabilité des conseils
départementaux et relève de la
protection de l'enfance s'ils sont
majeurs
ils sont pris en charge par l'état pour
mémoire notre pays consacrerait 500
millions d'euros à la prise en charge de
ces mineurs étrangers
il serait de l'ordre de 8000 présents
sur notre territoire et les flux annuel
d'arrivée serait de plusieurs milliers
au point où les forces de l'ordre
commencent à se demander si une filière
clandestine voire mafieuses ne serait
pas en train de s'organiser pour exemple
l'ille-et-vilaine figurent dans le top
10 des départements accueillant ces
mineurs étrangers comme la
seine-saint-denis du président bartolone
qui pourraient utilement suivre
l'exemple de madame delga pour se
consacrer à sa campagne électorale des
régionales ne rêvez pas nos réponses
qu'ils ont est triple et la réponse
intéresse tous les présidents de
conseils départementaux combien
d'étrangers réellement mineurs entre
chaque année en france les magistrats
utilise-t-il systématiquement tous les
moyens de la circulaire taubira 2013
pour déterminer leur âge qu'amd aventure
il est prouvé que ces jeunes sont
majeurs que deviennent ils
merci la parole est à monsieur le
premier ministre
manuel valls
c'est le président vous plaît madame la
madame la députée jeu je sais bien que
le le débat public autorise tout n'en
fins d'accords si christiane taubira
assume ses obligations c'est son rôle
aussi et à chaque question mettre en
cause un ministre
et en l'occurrence la garde des sceaux
parce qu'elle est un rassemblement
particulièrement important je trouve ça
désobligeants deuxièmement
et d'aborder les vrais sujets ce
gouvernement agit ces mots fragiles ou
de violences urbaines avec la plus
grande fermeté
grâce au rôle bien sûr à l'engagement de
nos forces de l'ordre et vous connaissez
par ailleurs et vous savez parfaitement
l'engagement de bernard cazeneuve comme
celui qui a été le mien pendant deux ans
troisièmement la question des mineurs
c'est une question particulièrement
difficile difficile à traiter en
quelques minutes et encore plus à
exploiter politiquement comme vous le
chercher là de le faire en permanence
sur les questions d'immigration qui
préférait de ce point de vue là les
questions de monsieur bouchons et
monsieur guibal qui essayait avec
modération de traiter ces sujets là
n'exploitait pas ce sujet là
vous le savez la problématique des
mineurs est compliqué parce quand ils
vous paye des minots un nouveau plancher
est liée à des conventions
internationales
nous traitons ces questions avec les
ministres des affaires sociales de la
justice et de la famille
nous sommes en permanence d'ailleurs y
compris à rennes
et vous savez interpellé par les
associations et compris par des forces
spirituelles
regardez la une du monde aujourd'hui et
les propos et les propositions du pape
françois créton ces questions
intelligemment trouvons des solutions
avec les collectivités territoriales
plutôt que les s'écharper sur ces
questions fondamentales
soyons positifs et trouver ensemble les
bonnes solutions
merci monsieur le premier ministre